Hello world,
it's Suraj and I'm going to list 10 people that I admire today.
In no particular order.
These amazing people are a mix of AI researchers,
blockchain researchers,
philosophers,
storytellers,
and artists that I personally look up to and gain inspiration from.
So hopefully by sharing them with you,
you too can learn from them a link to all of them in the video description and
remember to hit the subscribe button if you want to keep up with all of my
educational content.
Number one is naval Ravikant.
Nevada is the founder of the popular Angel List website,
which aims to connect startups to the resources they need,
like investors and initial hires.
He invested in some of the most valuable companies that exist today early on and
has an eye for spotting potential,
but he's much more than that.
Neval has a way with words.
I follow him on Twitter and some of his tweet storms just make me sit back and
question the foundational structures of society.
He's really into blockchain technology mostly for its potential to reorganize
the fabric of humanity.
And if Nietzsche were alive today,
his tweets would probably look very similar to Nevada and the Internet is going
to become a giant grid.
Additionally,
some of his blog posts are worthy of Pulitzer prizes.
He's able to connect the dots between politics,
technology,
religion,
and social media in a way very few people can.
Number two is oriel venules in almost every single AI paper that matters a lot
to me.
Oreo is listed as one of the authors neural machine translation,
which improved language translation immensely.
Sequence to sequence learning,
which brought chatbots to a whole new level wave net,
which was one of the top three advances in all of deep learning last year,
a new standard in speech recognition.
I was really excited when he was listed as one of the 35 innovators under 35 by
MIT technology review.
Clearly Oriol is onto something.
His ideas are pointing in the right direction for where we should be headed in
terms of research and what are the avenues worth experimenting with.
Number three is Andrew Trask.
When I first started making videos about AI almost two years ago,
I remembered stumbling on a blog post by Trask on how a neural network works.
At the time,
it was by far the best technical explanation I'd ever seen on how a neural
network works.
Thinking about gradient descent,
like dropping a ball into a bowl.
Now that's an analogy that I can understand as opposed to the dozens of other
tutorials that forced me to think about it in terms of concepts I wasn't as
familiar with.
Trask later collaborated with me on the deep learning course.
I taught at Iu Udacity and there I got to know him a bit better.
Later on,
we met up in London where I interviewed him for the channel.
We ended up getting along really well.
Andrew gets it.
He understands that data is the key to democratizing AI and he's working on
solving this problem full time right now as he builds the open mind to
community.
He's one of the best technical writers alive right now.
Number four,
Balaji Srinivasan.
I remember watching his talk on exit at y Combinator,
startup school,
Uber,
Airbnb,
Stripe Square,
and of course,
you know,
the big one,
Bitcoin,
uh,
are all things that threaten dcs power.
It is not necessarily clear that the u s government can ban something that it
wants to ban any.
It was a revolutionary idea that silicon valley should secede from the United
States and his reasoning relating the US constitution to deprecated code
networks as nation states and geographic communities to cloud communities
fundamentally changed the way I view the world.
Balaji's tweet storms are really insightful and his new startup earned.com is
probably the most successful implementation in production of blockchain
technology out there right now.
And it's because he's been thinking about this stuff for so long.
His list of accomplishments are pretty long and overall his view on where things
are headed,
our unparalleled number five,
Brian Johnson,
Brian puts his money where his mouth is.
He grew up in a modest family and earned his wealth over the years.
He made huge amounts of money with his previous startup brain tree and decided
to put 100 million of his own money to fund his current venture.
Colonel Colonel is dedicated to building a brain computer interface.
Essentially,
they want to build a device that connects your brain to the Internet.
Solving AI and connecting our brains to the Internet are two of the most
important problems of our time.
If we do that,
we literally become limitless in our ability to do anything.
So when people say to me they think I'm crazy for what I'm trying to do,
I would say I would be crazy not to.
I had the opportunity to meet Brian at his office in La a few weeks ago,
and the conversations we had had me thinking for hours afterwards.
He's trying to create an environment where discoveries happen and the best
discoveries tend to happen by accident like that of DNA.
Every day he wakes up excited to solve that problem and it's really inspiring.
Number six,
Tristan Harris.
I first heard Tristan Harris while listening to a podcast by a modern
philosopher I really like named Sam Harris and he blew me away.
The thing is that any attention based companies,
snapchat,
Netflix,
um,
uh,
you know,
meditation after even they all need more attention to be successful.
He used to be a design ethicist at Google,
but is now working full time on what he calls the time well spent movement.
Basically he sees how these big tech companies are creating algorithms that are
optimizing for users attention since that's what fuels their ad revenue business
model.
And these algorithms have become runaway AI eyes.
Even the creators don't understand how they fully work.
The Facebook newsfeed is an example of that and this poses an existential
threat.
The content it shows us isn't necessarily good for us.
It's just what grabs our attention.
Tourists and argues that instead of optimizing for attention,
they should be optimizing for our time well spent content that would benefit the
users as AI development accelerates.
Now more than ever,
we need someone like Tristan helping guide AI so that it's built in a safe
beneficial way.
Number seven Tupac Shakur.
Okay.
I know this one is kind of random and I know Tupac rapped about violence and
drugs,
but what I find most inspiring about him is the amount of courage he had.
Tupac wasn't afraid of anyone or anything.
He spoke his truth during the time of real political and social turmoil in
America.
Very few people had the kind of charisma that Tupac had and he was a man with a
plan.
You just wanted to follow him despite being constantly degraded by the media and
the police.
He fought for what he believed in a brighter future for people in poverty.
He never lost sight of who he was.
Number eight,
Kwan Bennet one was my roommate back in San Francisco for a bit and I worked
with him a bit on his project.
The interplanetary file system,
IPFS and file coin are an implementation of quants,
greater vision for the web.
When one talks about blockchains and distributed hash tables,
he makes things seem not just possible,
but simple to achieve that wouldn't have otherwise.
We built IPFS a protocol to remove those central points of failure to improve
the resilience of the Internet and the web and to give information and a
stronger sense of permanence.
He has this thirst for knowledge that's really inspiring and when he talks about
the pioneers of the web from burners lead to Bram Cohen,
he makes you realize that you too could come up with a great idea.
If you build a great protocol,
people will use it and it'll become a key part of the web.
IPFS is a beautiful system and I could tell that he'd really done his
distributed systems research.
When I read it,
it's people like Kwan that will move the web and as a result,
all of humanity forward.
Number nine,
Steve Jobs,
say what you want about Steve Jobs.
Say that he was hard to work with or he wasn't doing the real engineering behind
Apple's products,
but no one can say Steve jobs wasn't an inspirational speaker.
When jobs spoke,
people listened.
Apple Apple's place in is totally different and believe me,
the products and the distribution and manufacturing,
we understand that
what values and core values,
those things shouldn't change.
He was able to weave a story into the fabric of the company he was creating,
giving apple something more to believe in than just building products.
I've read his biography and I've probably seen every single Steve jobs video
that exists at this point.
He's truly one of a kind.
Number 10 is trends,
mcconaughey,
kind of like Andrew Trask.
Trent is one of the few people that understand both artificial intelligence and
blockchain technology really well.
Not only that,
Trent understands the need to democratize access to data and he's working on it
full time on ocean protocol.
His blog posts about AI and blockchain show his deep understanding of how these
technologies intertwined and the way they've raised money by putting a very
small cap on investment shows that it's not about the money,
it's about the mission.
There are so many more people I could have mentioned here,
shout out to Elon Musk,
but we all know who he is.
Is there someone that really inspires you,
post their name and why?
In the comments section,
please subscribe for more programming videos.
And for now I've got to get inspired,
so thanks for watching.